the most feared corporate Raider in the
world one of the cutest investors on the
planet he moves markets by the mere
mention of his name you have a bombshell
today from short seller Hindenburg
research which is revealing a new short
position against Carl icahn's IEP
Fortune Magazine says he may be making
more money for shareholders than anyone
else on the planet
on October 31st 2012 Carl Icahn
announced that he had purchased a 10
stake in Netflix this was really a
Halloween spook for Netflix as icon was
someone that you didn't want anywhere
near your company
people like icon constantly assure you
that oh it's just a passive investment
I'm not trying to take over the company
and then boom you get sued for depicting
Cleopatra as black wait uh never mind
wrong result boom icon shows up with
enough money to buy you out cash back in
2012 this wasn't even that hard as
Netflix was only worth four to five
billion dollars which was nothing for
Carl Icahn he had orchestrated a 8
billion buyouts way back in the 80s so 4
billion in 2012 was Child's Play with a
net worth of 21 billion dollars he could
literally buy out Netflix with a
personal loan and that was probably what
he was planning on doing it despite his
hollow promises
flex's executive team would scramble
trying to find a way to fend off this
bully and they would end up implementing
a defense called the poison pill the
poison pill could be somewhat effective
but it was by no means a foolproof
defense all Netflix could do though was
a nervously wait and hoped that they
don't hear about another purchase but
weeks went by months it went by and at
full years went by no new purchases in
fact icon would even go ahead and sell
off his entire stake by mid-2015
had the poison pill really worked had
the Netflix just fended off the infamous
Coral icon no way icon was actually
being honest about his passive
intentions right well probably not and I
don't think he was put off by the poison
pill either the reality is that icon had
lost his Mojo while his net worth had
gone up over the years his days in power
toying with Fortune 10 companies were
long gone it wasn't just icon who was in
this situation either corporate Raiders
as a whole had lost their power back in
the days these guys were the worst
nightmares of small companies and their
shareholders with financing from Wall
Street Raiders would March into random
companies where they were not welcome
and to buy out a large portion of the
company if not the entire company after
that they would go on to fire a large
portion of the workforce increase
efficiency no matter the cost and to
bolster the stock price through any
means possible
once the company has been milked Raiders
will happily sell off the remaining
pull-up to some random soccer before
moving on to their next victim this was
the Brash and ruthless job of being a
corporate Raider but while this was no
doubt a nasty job it was also lucrative
till recently icon was worth over 20
billion dollars but today he is fighting
against accusations that he's been
running upon D which has crushed his net
worth down to just under 8 billion
dollars so here's the insane story of
how icon went from playing with Fortune
10 companies to being accused of fraud
taking a look back corporate rating does
not have an extensive history like stock
BuyBacks or dual class talk it Rose in
popularity during an era and then
disappeared shortly after there were a
few instances of corporate raiding
throughout the late 1960s but corporate
rating it didn't really become a thing
until Carl Icahn icon started off as
nothing more than an average Kid born in
1946 to a Jewish family in Brooklyn New
York his family was squarely in the
middle class with both of icon's parents
being School teachers but this didn't
hold him back from getting into
Princeton University and graduating with
a degree in philosophy in 1957. at first
it seems that he wanted to be a doctor
as he would enroll in the NYU school of
medicine but he would end up dropping
out and joining the military Reserve
forces
he would follow this up with a
traditional job on Wall Street as a
stockbroker in 1961. here he would learn
the ins and outs of stocks options bonds
warrants and other Financial products
before opening his own company called
icon and Company in 1968. from the very
beginning icon was especially interested
in leveraging Market inefficiencies but
he was by no means buying out entire
companies rather his company was focused
on something called the Arbitrage
trading this is basically when you make
money by leveraging discrepancies in
market pricing between different markets
and exchanges for example Tesla stock
might be worth 100 on TD Ameritrade but
to be worth 101 dollars on Robinhood in
this case it would make sense to buy
Tesla stock on TD and then instantly
sell the stake on Robinhood you would
only make one dollar per share but if
you did this with a hundred thousand
shares well then you're making serious
money that's just an example though as
it's not nearly that easy such blatant
pricing discrepancies are extremely rare
you'd be lucky to find a 5 or 10 cent
discrepancy on popular stocks but you'll
have a much better chance if you look
deeper than just common stock for
example you could look at the debt
Market many companies issue bonds that
can be converted to stock at a set ratio
so theoretically you could buy a Tesla
convertible Bond and convert it into 10
shares of Tesla stock if you're all in
cost for the bond is less than the
current price of 10 Tesla shares well
then you're golden
you can just sell the 10 shares and make
money this is precisely how icon made
his initial money he was constantly
looking for discrepancies between
options preferred stock common stock
bonds warrants and mutual funds he was
constantly converting between these
assets to generate a profit many people
aren't big fans of Market Arbitrage as
they see people like icon as Bottom
Feeders they basically scrape buy and
make a bunch of money without adding any
real value to the world
the argument against this would be that
arbitragers make markets more efficient
but I don't think icon was too concerned
about justifying his means to anyone as
it wasn't long until he jumped into
something much more controversial
much of the popularity of corporate
rating throughout the 70s and 80s can be
explained by the economic environment
interest rates were extraordinarily high
at up to 19 at first glance this might
sound like a great thing as you can just
store your cash in a savings account and
earn a warrant profit level returns
until you consider inflation inflation
also reached up to 15 so rarely were you
making any sort of real return this
didn't just apply to savings accounts
either whether you were looking at real
estate or stocks or gold or index funds
chances were high that there was no real
return this made investors especially
desperate and risk tolerant they were
willing to do just about anything
including piling into junk Bonds in fact
Between 1979 and 1989 the junk bond
market exploded from 10 billion dollars
to 189 billion dollars
but our Mana icon had a much better
pitch for investors given that people
were shying away from stocks the market
had stagnated for about 10 years and
many blue chip stocks were heavily
discounted this was a great opportunity
for Value investors like Warren Buffett
but icon didn't stop at just investing
in these value companies icon would
purchase a controlling share or the
entire company and he would quote
unquote optimize the company by optimize
he would basically strip these companies
down to their Bare Bones and eliminate
anything that wasn't generating a profit
this might not sound too bad Until you
realize just what he was eliminating
for example he might go in and kill a
company's r d department or their safety
department this would make the company
more profitable than ever for the next
three to five years but after that
they're absolutely screwed this was none
of icon's concern though as he would
have already flipped the business by
this point so essentially icon and his
fellow corporate Raiders were basically
going around and ruining companies for
personal gain icon's first Target was an
appliance company called Tappan he would
require a controlling stake in the
company in 1978 and do some gutting he
would then Force the company to be sold
to Electrolux Nanny gamma gross profit
of 2.7 million dollars or a 100 return
with a taste of success icon would
quickly jump up to playing with the tens
of millions in 1983 for example he would
acquire ACF Industries and flip it to
Philips Petroleum in 1985 for a 15
million dollar profit at least with
these two instances icon was simply
flipping these companies in other
instances he would straight up blackmail
these companies as was the case with sax
Industries icon bought a steak in Saxon
in 1980 and it threatened that he was
going to find someone to buy the entire
company this forced the company to buy
out icon shares which netted him a quick
2 million
seeing this there was no doubt that icon
was wreaking havoc quite early on but no
one really fought him
the companies that he was going after
were no name brands with not much
support surely he couldn't pull this off
with a true giant or at least that's
what they thought until he did
[Music]
in 1985 icon would pull together all of
his investors funds and then max out his
bank credit lines to purchase a 20 stake
in trans World Airlines for
approximately 70 million dollars most of
you probably aren't familiar with
Transworld Airlines or TWA well because
icon would run it to the ground but
we'll get to that
when icon purchased his stake TWA was
the fourth largest airline in the US in
fact their planes alone were worth over
a billion dollars which was massive
stuff for 1985. this isn't to say that
they were perfect though they were
dealing with issues with unions and
trying to Stage a turnaround but icon's
presence ensured that this turnaround
never came just a few months after his
initial purchase icon would up his stick
to just over 50 to which gave him
control of TWA
a few years later icon would take TWA
completely private upping his dick to 90
percent
during a normal corporate turnaround
businesses would focus on eliminating
the bad parts of the business and the
doubling down on the good parts but icon
would do the exact opposite he would
eliminate the good parts of the business
by selling them off for example he would
sell off their popular London routes to
American Airlines for 445 million
dollars pretty soon TWA had nothing left
but losses and they would unsurprisingly
evolved for bankruptcy in early 1992
with 540 million dollars in debt this
didn't really matter for Icon though as
he had already secured 469 million
dollars worth of profit for himself
the story of TWA definitely made some
waves on the new Cycles back in the 80s
but it wasn't icon that really turned
everyone against corporate Raiders that
honor actually goes to one-off icon's
biggest Rivals t-boon Pickens in the
early 1980s Pickens would launch a
hostile takeover against Gulf oil this
was absolutely unprecedented because
Gulf oil wasn't just a massive company
they were straight up a fortune 10
company
fortunately the Standard Oil Company of
California or Chevron was able to step
in and buy out the entire company for 13
billion dollars which prevented Pickens
from wreaking any Havoc but while this
did Salvage golf oil it also gave
Pickens a profit of 760 million dollars
pretty soon icon was also playing with
mega billion dollar companies in 1986
for example he launched an 8 billion
takeover of U.S steel he never succeeded
in taking over the entire company but
that didn't stop him from making a cool
200 million dollars
his biggest profit however came in 1989
when he sold his two billion dollars
taken Texaco for a 700 million profit
things had gone way too far and enough
was enough these tycoons were playing
around with Fortune 10 and Fortune 100
companies as if they were lemonade
stands companies were understandably not
just annoyed but triggered and pretty
soon they would start fighting back
one of the first defenses that came
about against corporators was the poison
pill defense you may have heard about
this with Twitter as they were indeed
using this defense this defense
basically consists of diluting the
corporator into Oblivion by issuing a
crap ton of shares this way the
corporator is never able to acquire
majority control of the company through
the public markets this is actually how
Netflix defended themselves against icon
right after icon purchased a 10 person
stake on Netflix Netflix would adopt a
poison-filled defense this may have been
successful at preventing icon from
buying out Netflix but this didn't stop
icon from making 800 million dollars
nonetheless though he would have made 40
billion if you just held on anyway
another popular strategy that companies
adopted was golden parachutes this
doesn't actually do anything to save the
company or shareholders but it does save
the executives essentially golden
parachutes allow for executives to walk
away with massive pounds if the company
gets acquired Twitter's Executives for
example walked away with over a hundred
million dollars in Severance to be
honest I wouldn't call this a defense
this is more of a case of Executives
saving their asses a more traditional
defense though is the White Knight
defense we briefly touched on this
actually with the gulf oil and the
tibune Pickens remember how Gulf oil
sold themselves to Chevron to avoid
Pickens that's a white knight defense
selling yourself to a friendly party to
avoid a takeover from a hostile party
there are a bunch of other defenses as
well like the green male defense and the
Employee Stock ownership defense and
many of these have been used to
successfully defend companies from
Texaco and Gucci to Netflix and Twitter
but none of these strategies really took
down corporate rating sure they made
corporate rating harder but they by no
means made it impossible or
non-lucrative
heck the richest man in the world today
Bernard Arno made most of his fortune by
raiding the fashion industry throughout
the 80s and 90s and Elon literally just
did one with the Twitter so it's
definitely still possible but then why
has corporate rating become so rare well
the primary reason is because investors
walked away back in the late 1900s
making a hundred percent return within
three or four years was unheard of but
thanks to tech stocks it's been largely
normalized this isn't to say that a 100
return within three to four years isn't
a phenomenal return it is a phenomenal
return but there's simply far more
opportunities to make such returns
meta for example has recovered nearly
200 within the past six months itself so
why be the villain destroy companies and
take on so much risk when you can just
bet on up and coming Blue Chip companies
and make the same or even better returns
with far less stress
the answer is no reason at all
all of the people who would have backed
someone like icon in the 80s have simply
turned to backing someone like
Zuckerberg or piche or Bitcoin and that
right there is what truly killed
corporate rating
today icon is being plagued with a
completely new controversy at the
beginning of May hinderberg research
accused that icon has been paying out
dividends using funds from new investors
and the given that Hindenburg has a
pretty good track record from taking
down Nikola Motors to taking down the
adani group it's very possible that
these accusations are indeed legitimate
but only time will tell
in the end corporate rating was an
invention that came from investors
desire for outsized returns over
everything else
this allowed for several Raiders to rise
to prominence who played with billion
dollar companies on a regular basis as
they made billions for themselves and
their investors
eventually though companies started
catching on and started fighting back
with varying levels of success
there's also an argument to be made that
Banks became more reluctant to lend to
corporators as a lot of Raiders simply
failed but really the bigger Trend that
killed off corporate rating was the rise
of tech investors simply found a new
shiny thing to invest in why flip
Appliance and oil companies when you
Combat on tech companies that reach
billions of people
and that is what marked the end of the
hunt for Carl Icahn the infamous Legend
who tried to buy Netflix do you think
some companies deserve to be rated if
you do comment those companies down
below
also drop a like to pay respects to all
of the companies that icon destroyed
and of course consider checking out our
Discord Community such as fertility
ideas and consider subscribing to see
more questions logically answered but
until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next one